imagine we have a beautiful article with
us what if we want to make a copy of it
the best way would be to make use of a
cast or a mold similar strategies are
used by ourselves the most important
task for a cell is to synthesize
proteins based on the codes in DNA but
how are these codes read what's the
process that helps decode this language
and are proteins synthesized merely by
the sequence of ATG and C the answer to
all questions lies in the central dogma
of life but what exactly is the central
dogma well DNA makes copies of itself by
the process of replication post
replication in every cell the code of
the DNA is cracked and transcribed into
a messenger RNA this mRNA is then read
and the code is translated into proteins
this interesting concept it's nothing
but the central dogma
we know that the replication process is
semiconservative in nature so now our
focus will be on the two processes
namely transcription and translation
let's begin with transcription first as
we can see here the process in which M
RNA is synthesized based on the parent
DNA template is called transcription the
part or segment of DNA which encodes for
a particular protein is called gene so
how about proteins made from the
sequence of base pairs in the gene let's
go in the reverse direction now proteins
are a specific sequence of amino acids
so the various amino acids come together
in a specific series to form a chain
that makes up the proteins
now to get the amino acids in a series
we need a set of instructions these are
present in the form of mRNA and where
does the mRNA come from it is
synthesized from a special template can
you guess what this template is give it
a shot
that's right the template is a gene so a
segment of the DNA that encodes for
protein is copied first the copy is in
the form of M RNA this process of making
M RNA is called transcription now can
you tell me why this process is needed
well it's quite simple if there is no
transcription then who will M RNA be
synthesized and if that's not done then
how will the proteins be made
hence transcription is vital but it's
not as easy as it seems there are
several enzymes and sub steps involved
in the process we are referring to the
steps like opening of the DNA double
helix at a specific point assembling the
set of enzymes gathering of nucleotides
and so on after all these steps and M
RNA is formed the m RNA is like an exact
copy of the DNA sequence that coats the
protein the only difference between the
two is that M RNA is single-stranded and
the base thymine is replaced by uracil
not that the M RNA is ready it's all set
to enter the cytoplasm that is where the
next step begins it's the translation
process let's have a look at this
interesting process in the upcoming part
imagine you're appearing for an exam but
the paper presented to you is in a
language that you don't understand you
are prepared for the exam but
interpretation of the questions is a
problem what can be done some help from
a translator would work wonders right so
translation is the simplest way to solve
this problem clearly a wise move would
be to decode the unrecognizable language
and then attempt the exam now imagine
this cell to be in a similar situation
let's assume that this cell encounters a
set of instructions for performing a
task but the instructions are written in
a coded language so all it needs to do
is to translate this language and then
perform the task any idea which process
are we talking about that's right we are
talking about the translation process in
continuation with the process of
transcription from the previous part
let's now understand the next step of
the central dogma of life as the name
suggests translation means converting
something into a simpler understandable
form and what's getting translated here
that's correct the code hidden in the
mRNA molecule the process of
transcription helps in copying the code
written on the DNA that means it forms
the mRNA now the mRNA comes out of the
nucleus through the nuclear pore and
enters the cytoplasm here the process of
translation begins to begin with let's
find out the directionality of this mRNA
molecule this is the five prime end of
the mRNA and this is the three prime end
and how do we know this I'll be randomly
stating this no it's not random we can't
recognize these ends with the help of
specific markers the three prime end has
a continuous series of the a nucleotides
this region is
called the poly a tail the 5-prime end
on the other hand has a cap of methyl
group does this end is said to be
methylated but why is the directionality
needed well it's extremely important the
assembly that carries out transcription
binds to the mRNA near the 5-prime end
so how does the assembly know that this
is the five prime end the easiest way to
recognize the five prime end is by the
presence of this methyl cap this is how
the assembly understands to bind near
the five prime end and not to the poly a
tail now what exactly is this assembly
that we're referring to well that's the
ribosome unit two units of ribosomes one
small and one large form an assembly
that helps in the process ribosomes are
basically a complex assembly which acts
like a molecular machine for protein
synthesis remember the small dots
attached to the surface of the rough
endoplasmic reticulum we find them in
the diagram of a typical cell these are
nothing but ribosomes so the ribosomes
are usually made up of two subunits a
smaller and a larger one the smaller
subunit binds to the mRNA at the
initiation site once this is done the
larger subunit binds and completes the
assembly now the other type of RNA
called tRNA steps in to get the
remaining work done at the end a chain
of amino acids is formed and released
from the dry bozo Mille unit so doesn't
this chain of amino acids look familiar
you got that right it's our protein the
chain is further modified to achieve a
proper configuration so that the protein
becomes functional this is how the
translation process works the cord of
mRNA is translated and the protein chain
is synthesized out of it the process of
description and translation together are
called as gene expression the code of a
gene is transcribed first and then
translated into the form of proteins
there is an extremely important thing to
note here whatever we've talked so far
is all about the processes in eukaryotes
such high level of organization is found
only in eukaryotes
but we know what eukaryotes are right a
cell with a well-defined nucleus and a
highly organized system is a eukaryotic
cell on the other hand cells which lack
of proper membrane-bound nucleus and
organization are called prokaryotic
cells since they lack the proper
membrane bound organelles and nucleus
they do not undergo such complex and
sophisticated processes so the
replication process in prokaryotes is
slightly different this was a brief idea
about the transcription and translation
process as seen in the eukaryotes for
more interesting concepts in genetics
tune in to our Channel and don't forget
to subscribe
[Music]